let's bring in texas republican senator
ted cruz right now he joins us
senator you tweeted as we pointed out a
moment ago you'll be curious to see
whether president biden now takes out
the mask
as a result of this latest cdc guidance
what are you thinking about the fact now
that fully vaccinated people can go
masculine
in many many situations well my reaction
to the cdc's announcement
is it's about damn time that we should
be following the science and not playing
politics and and from the beginning of
covid
there's been far too much politics
connected to it look when it comes to
mask i've never understood the extreme
on either side i've never been one of
those people who said never wear a mask
i would wear a mask on an airplane when
i went to a grocery store
particularly when the pandemic was
raging but once i got my vaccine once
other
people were getting vaccinated i stopped
wearing masks and
and i got to say i think joe biden and
kamala harris have been playing
politics with covid19 and and
they've been playing politics by keeping
schools shut down the science is
absolutely clear
kids should be in school in person today
the science is unequivocal on that
but they also were playing politics on
masks that it never made any sense
once you were vaccinated to wear a mask
and and unfortunately
biden and harris and the administration
kept saying wear a mask wear a mask wear
a mask even if you're vaccinated
that discouraged a lot of people from
getting the vaccine so i think the
message people ought to hear
is get the vaccine stop the spread of
the disease it ought to be voluntary
but you should be encouraged to get the
vaccine and one of the great virtues
when you get the vaccine
you can take the damn mask off and and
return
to to regular life that should encourage
millions more people to choose to get
the vaccine we're thankful those masks
helped us when we needed them we're also
very many of us are going to be uh
thankful for the day we can put them
down which seems to be today senator
uh just two hours ago it struck me a
tweet that you put out
four months into the biden presidency
and we already have
and you checked off a border crisis a
gas crisis
a war in the middle east and we're on
the verge of an inflation
crisis how would you characterize the
politics of this moment
well look the first four months of the
biden administration have been the most
radical of any administration in history
and unfortunately
joe biden has decided to hand over the
agenda
to the extreme left in his party so the
people driving the substance
are bernie sanders and elizabeth warren
and aoc and we're seeing
six trillion dollars in new spending
proposed we're seeing trillions
in new taxes proposed we're seeing the
border absolute chaos the worse it's
been in 20 years and it's getting worse
and worse and worse
because joe biden and kamala harris
won't enforce the law
and and we're saying domestically
a crisis we're seeing economically a
crisis the inflation that is coming when
you spend six trillion dollars we don't
have and you print the money
you create inflation and then abroad in
just a few months biden's managed to
undermine our friends and allies to
undermine
israel to send hundreds of millions of
dollars to the palestinian authorities
and and hamas and to promise the
ayatollah khamenei
billions of dollars and what's the
reward for that hamas is raining rockets
on israel
with money that comes from the ayatollah
khamenei and and and this is
we are seeing crisis after crisis after
crisis
because the biden harris policies are
radical and extreme
and they don't work yes senator we're
we're just getting some museum from our
jerusalem
uh fox bureau it may not just be hamas
that's raining rockets down on
israel dvoralinsky of our jerusalem
bureau reports
that for the first time during current
fighting rockets have been fired into
israel
from lebanon's territory if hezbollah
which is also supported by iran is now
getting involved
uh where could this go i mean i'm
reminded of what happened back in 2006.
look we are on the verge of a full-scale
war in the middle east and it's worth
pausing and reflecting
what a different place we were in six
months ago under the trump
administration
the the administration and the president
made very clear that america stands
unequivocally with israel we've moved
our embassy to jerusalem i urge
president trump to do that
i was there the day we opened our
embassy we pulled out of the disastrous
obama iran nuclear deal something else
that i urged the president to do and it
produced
this incredible blossoming this
flowering of peace
it produced the abraham accords you know
i spoke with the foreign ministers and
ambassadors of bahrain and uae
when the abraham accords were signed and
both said to me almost exactly the same
thing
they said listen it is clear that
america stands unequivocally with israel
we want to be friends with america so
therefore
we will be friends with israel and
that's exactly what i had urged the
trump administration that if we're clear
if there's no ambiguity it will make it
obvious to our
friends and our enemies where we stand
when joe biden came in
his radical politics screwed all of that
up they've been
undermining israel one of the things
they did so there's legislation i helped
pass called the taylor force act the
taylor force act is named after a texan
taylor force who was a u.s military
veteran
he was killed by terrorists in israel
and hamas
sends money every year to the families
of the terrorists who murder americans
and murder israelis
the taylor force act says we won't send
taxpayer money
to any government any organization that
pays terrorists to murder americans
or murder our allies well joe biden
decided to ignore that law to violate
that law
and so he has resumed sending over a
hundred million dollars to the
palestinian authority
and to hamas that lesson is not lost
on any of the terrorists and right now
they're reigning rockets down on israel
with impunity
because they don't believe joe biden or
kamala harris
we'll do a single thing about it senator
i wonder what your message is to those
members of congress that are criticizing
the biden administration including
alexandria ocasio-cortez
criticizing the president for standing
with israel
and also rashida talib another member of
the so-called squad claiming israel is
promoting racism
and dehumanization under apartheid
system
well look unfortunately that that is the
the
driving force in today's democratic
party it's the angry socialist
left aoc and rashida talib and ilhan
omar
who who are tweeting things that that
frankly are indistinguishable
from what they'd be saying if they were
actually the press secretaries for hamas
you've got omar who is accusing israel
of carrying out acts of terrorism there
is a fundamental difference
between a nation defending itself
against terrorists
and terrorists targeting women and
children which is what hamas is doing
you know i'm reminded of something that
that prime minister netanyahu said a
number of years ago and
and over the years prime minister
netanyahu and i have become good friends
and he made the following observation he
said in israel
we use our missiles to defend our
citizens
hamas uses their citizens to defend
their missiles because they locate in
gaza
the caches of missiles in in the
basements of kindergartens
in hospitals because they're literally
using
palestinian children as human shields to
protect the missiles
that they want to murder israeli
children with and and it is disgraceful
that you have members of the united
states congress that basically operate
as
shills for terrorists and undermine
israel and they undermine israel so
often
that after a while you start to say okay
we we get it
you don't like the jews it's not subtle
it's not
new but but it is a very ugly sentiment
particularly to see in the united states
congress
so we're just getting an update on what
i told you a moment ago senator about
rockets being fired from
lebanon uh mayor of an israeli town near
the lebanese border according to reuters
we don't know which town it is but
there's a number of small towns there
iran
vavim carrier is up there matula as well
three rockets were fired apparently no
casualties
so the fact that there's no casualties
that's good news let me just switch if i
could to the gas shortage
yeah you tweeted earlier today welcome
to the green new deal
but this thing with the pipeline didn't
have anything to do with a green new
deal i mean it might at some point in
the future
but this is all about not securing our
critical infrastructure
what does the white house need to do to
ensure that bad actors
in places like russia can't collapse our
fuel supply system in the southeast
with with just a single push of a button
sure look there is no doubt that there
are real threats to our critical
infrastructure and cyber attacks from
russia from china
from iran from north korea from other
bad actors are a big part of it and we
need to do much more to secure our
infrastructure
but i'll tell you the connection to the
green new deal is the vision of biden
and aoc
as a vision that on day one in the white
house joe biden shut down the keystone
pipeline
they're doing everything they can to
shut down oil and gas production in the
united states
and and we're getting a a foreshadowing
of what the world of the green new deal
is like
shutting down one pipeline suddenly
people can't get gas to put in their
cars to go to work
that's just one pipeline and this is the
the world
that that that biden and pelosi are are
trying to force on this country it it it
makes no sense
it's dangerous we need to be instead
expanding american energy independence
today america is the number one producer
of oil in the world and the number one
producer of natural gas
that changes the geopolitical chess
board we used to be dependent on the
middle east
for oil and gas now we're the energy
superpower and joe biden and kamala
harris are trying to mess that up
let me say one other thing also we were
just talking a minute ago about israel
one of the real challenges israel faces
right now is their iron dome missiles
the interceptors
are taking out these rockets one after
the other after the other i'll tell you
something joe biden could do today
to show decisive presidential leadership
he could stand up and say
we're going to replenish israel's iron
dome missiles by the way these missiles
never are aimed at people they're aimed
at incoming rockets
that are trying to murder innocent
civilians the biden administration needs
to act today to ensure
that israel has an adequate supply of
iron dome missiles
senator finally from the crisis in the
middle east to the ongoing crisis at our
southern border it's been 50 days now
and counting that kamala harris
has been put in charge of the situation
at the border she hasn't held a news
conference she has not visited the
border
i know you're calling it a dereliction
of duty
what should happen next and and and if
she continues to ignore the situation
or not visit the border or not hold a
news conference how bad does it get
look there is zero leadership right now
to solve this problem that the approach
of joe biden and kamala harris is is to
pretend the crisis doesn't exist
as you know just over a month ago i
brought a group of 19 senators down to
the border to see firsthand what's
happening there
i've been to the to the rio grande
valley many many times representing the
state of texas i have never seen it
remotely this bad
there were 178 000 people who crossed
illegally last month
every month is higher than the month
before we're on a path to see over 2
million people coming here illegally
we have thousands and thousands of
people packed in over capacity
uh cages and the biden cages are bigger
and more full
that than they've ever been in the midst
of a pandemic where coveted positivity
is over ten percent joe biden pretends
it doesn't exist he pretends it's not a
crisis he put kamala harris in charge
if she's in charge i mean goodness
gracious can you imagine if someone put
kamala
harris in charge of a hot dog stand and
in 50 days she never went to the hot dog
stand she's done nothing she literally
went
to the canadian border in new hampshire
before she's gone to the southern border
and i've joked you know last i've
checked
there are not thousands of canucks
streaming across
our northern border and you know there's
a reason sandra
that neither biden nor harris want to go
to the southern border
because they know if they come tv
cameras will follow
and they can't solve this problem
because there's a way to solve the
problem
the way to solve the problem is resume
building the ball resume
building the wall and return to the
remain in mexico policy a successful
international agreement president trump
negotiated
that resulted in last year we had the
lowest rate of illegal immigration
in 45 years
pause and reflect on that we know how to
succeed in this
because last year remain in mexico
produced the lowest rates in 45 years
joe biden
in his first week in office ripped that
international agreement
to pieces and it's causing this spike
and the reason biden and harris
won't go to the border is they promised
the far left radical activists
that they won't enforce immigration laws
that they won't deport people
and given that there is no solution to
this crisis until they admit
their policies are wrong and that they
are hurting people it's not humane
children are being physically assaulted
sexually assaulted women
are being sexually assaulted disease
crime this is a humanitarian crisis and
it is joe biden and his political
decisions
that have caused it
it's a lot it's a lot happening it's a
lot for the american people to see
happening right now senator cruz thank
you for all the time this afternoon
thank you